let's answer the question what is the
first sign of a zinc
deficiency now clinically when you're
deficient in zinc
all sorts of things happen a lack of
growth
anorexia tissue necrosis you can
actually get tissue dying from a lack of
zinc
all sorts of skin issues all sorts of
digestive issues
infection viruses bacteria
hair loss ulcers and the list goes on
and on
you don't have a major deficiency but
you're just starting to become
deficient in zinc well to answer that we
need to kind of look at
some other data number one when you're
low in zinc
you will have a lowered amount of very
specific
antioxidants glutathione
alpha tocopherol and catalase
which has to do with the detoxification
of hydrogen peroxide
so in other words very powerful
antioxidants
in our bodies are dependent on
zinc and without zinc you will not be
able to produce these in sufficient
amounts
now there's some additional information
i want to share with you cardiac tissue
or heart tissue is the highest producer
of something called ross so just think
about ross as
something that creates a lot of
oxidation and the heart cells
as a tissue if we compare it to other
tissues in the body
has one the lowest antioxidant capacity
now what does that mean
so in other words it becomes very
susceptible to becoming
damaged this is probably why the number
one cause of death
is heart disease the heart is not able
to repair effectively
and the first symptom is you're going to
get shortness of breath
upon exertion so let's say
you start to exercise or you run up the
stairs
and you're out of breath easily that
would be the first symptom of a zinc
deficiency
so i remember as a kid living on sugar
outside playing and noticing i was
having a difficult time running up a
hill i was like out of breath very
easily i had no clue on what that was
but it was probably a zinc
deficiency due to all the sugar that was
consuming and so if you have that
symptom
watch a lot more of my videos on zinc i
put the links down below check it out
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this
course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today